alors quelle est votre réaction à la
mort de ce grand homme c'est un ardent
défenseur des droits des peuples
autochtones qui nous quitte aujourd'hui
oui absolument évidemment une réaction
de tristesse mes pensées vont d'abord à
la famille immédiate
ensuite à l'ensemble de la nation
huronne wendat max gros-louis c'était un
chien c'était vraiment quelqu'un qu'on
regardait avec beaucoup de respect et
c'est quelqu'un qui vole moins bon vous
dire c'est un chêne c'est une personne
qu'on regardait avec beaucoup de respect
pouvez vous nous dire un peu l'incidence
qu'il a eue le legs qu'il a pu laisser
pour les jeunes parce qu'ils semblent
c'est un homme qui lâchait jamais ça
envoie un message force à la communauté
à la jeunesse
oui est encore impliqués dernièrement
dans les élections qui viennent tout
juste d'avoir lieu
c'était quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup
pour l'affirmation des droits des
premières nations pour seulement pour sa
nation mais à travers 100 nations le
faisait pour l'ensemble des premières
nations du québec et du canada
max gros-louis il a été un des
fondateurs de l'association et diane du
québec qui est l'ancêtre de l'assemblée
des premières nations du québec et du
labrador alors ça c'est fort bien à la
fin des années 60 début des années 70
c'est beaucoup beaucoup impliqué pour
que les autochtones soient consultés
dans tout ce qui les regarde
vous savez ce fameux rien sur nous sans
nous dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
ben il avait un peu cette philosophie
lomax bobby dans tout ce qu'il faisait
notamment au niveau de gayssot de
l'affirmation des droits territoriaux
des premières nations des autochtones en
général c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
beaucoup aussi pour l'autonomie de
gestion de sa communauté de sa nation
c'est à dire que sous son règne sous sa
gouverne
on a pu rapatrier nos propres services
de santé nos services en éducation donc
si nous mêmes qui est en question à
mesure de gérer tout ce temps à partir
des années 80 il a aussi fait en sorte
qu'il y ait des bourses et des
programmes d aide financière pour les
étudiants wendat au postsecondaire donc
permis à des centaines voire des
milliers
deux membres de la nation huronne wendat
d'aller à l'université au cégep donc il
a énormément contribué à tout ce qui
s'est fait il a mené dès le territorial
aussi et parlez nous de son apport dans
ces négociations là sur la baie james
sur les territoires hydroélectrique
qu'il était là il était de toutes les
batailles
oui il était de toutes les batailles on
l'a vu aux côtés des grands lits de cris
nommément dans le début des années 70
dans cette grande bataille judiciaire
que les cris et les inuits ont eu en
lien avec le territoire et le
développement hydroélectrique à la baie
james
il a été de toutes les grandes batailles
jusqu'à la fin ce qui me marque le plus
concernant max gros-louis c'est le fait
que malgré le fait qu'il était un homme
respecté un diplomate hors du commun
il reconnaissait les gens ils
reconnaissaient les femmes il était
accessible il parlait à tout le monde
combien de fois il est venu me voir ils
sont bons jeux olympiques or alors que
ça faisait des années que je ne l'avais
pas vraiment dit devait changer
donc c'était quelqu'un vraiment qu'ils
regardaient et et au mois de février
dernier alors que j'ai fait l'émission
tout le monde en parle et l'appli mes
parents il a pris mon père pour le
féliciter et me féliciter à travers donc
c'est quelqu'un vraiment qu'ils étaient
présents partout tout à une personne
très accessible on en parlait avec
l'actuel chef de la nation huronne
wendat donc cet homme là est était
demeuré très près très très très près
des gens la communauté oui toujours
c'est quelqu'un qui saluait tout le
monde quand il se promenait dans son
camion il arrêtait pour parler à tout le
monde toujours puis possiblement des
membres de la communauté mais des
allochtones aussi je me souviens lui ou
nordique n'est qu'avec aux parties de
hockey
il a été président du fan club pendant
longtemps et on le voyait assis dans les
estrades avec son tambour pour
encourager les joueurs et là il s'est
lié d'amitié avec des centaines de
québécois et c'est comme ça aussi qui
s'est fait connaître
donc vraiment une bonne personne une
personne de kirk travaillait fort et qui
avaient à akkar l'affirmation des droits
des premières nations
pensez vous que la cause autochtone est
rendu là où il souhaitait qu'elle se
rende
je pense que oui lorsque je l'espère je
l'entendais dans une entrevue
dernièrement où il disait oui la loi d
et sur les indiens il faut qu'elle soit
repensé mais il faut que ce soit repensé
avec le concours et l'écoutent et la
participation des premières nations
donc je pense que on fait des grands pas
et il regardait avec fierté la relève et
les plus jeunes qui se lèvent
aujourd'hui et je pense qu'on le fait je
pense qu'il était content je l'espère en
tout cas
isabelle piquant ça a été un plaisir de
vous parler merci de nous avoir partagé
ses souvenirs et de nous avoir présenté
cet homme sous un autre jour aussi merci
d'avoir été là